this
gigantic bat was captured on camera by
a man filming his camping trip
he's been missing ever since
stories like these have been swirling
the internet for the past
couple of years with people using
pictures
and videos to supposedly prove that
human sized bats exist
but could bats really get that big
how dangerous would they be and
why could we make lots of money off
their
giant bat poop this
is what if and here's what would happen
if
bats were the size of humans
bats already creep a lot of people out
so
imagine how scared people would be if
there were
giant ones roaming around and
keep in mind that bats usually live
together in groups of 100 to several
thousand so if you run into one of these
giant beasts
chances are there'd be a whole army of
them nearby
would their natural ecosystems be able
to sustain these oversized bats
[Music]
to understand what a world with giant
bats
would be like let's get to know our
regular sized bats first
because there are so many different bat
species today we're just going to focus
on two
the flying fox and the vampire bat
[Music]
vampire bats have a wingspan of 35 to
40 centimeters they can run speeds of up
to 1.2 meters per second
and they really like to drink blood
they drink so much of it that they can
double their weight
in just one feeding so can you imagine
how bloodthirsty they'd be
if they were the size of humans
luckily for us bats don't get any bigger
than
our next featured player the flying fox
there are 60 flying fox species and the
largest one
has a wingspan of 1.7 meters
that might sound like it's getting
almost human sized but
the body is pretty small about 30
centimeters in length
[Music]
they have a surprisingly big brain for
such a small body
and they're said to be as intelligent as
dogs
so what would life be like if there were
millions of human-sized intelligent
blood-sucking bats roaming around
well let's find out
flying fox bats would need to be six
times bigger to become the size of a
human
their new head to toe length would be
170 centimeters
their new wingspan would be 10 meters
and their new weight would be 216
kilograms
they would need to eat about 19
kilograms of fruit
every day just to sustain themselves
with this new hunger they would easily
wipe out farms and orchards and
they disrupt the entire food chain
and then there's the vampire bat
don't worry they won't add any more
stress to our fruit farms because
they're only hungry for blood oh wait
that sounds even worse
human-sized vampire bats would be about
170 centimeters long
they'd have a wingspan of 6.8 meters
and a mass of 295 kilograms
because of their size they would be able
to drink
34 liters of blood per meal
if we want to save our necks we might
need to raise
livestock to offer up to the vampire
bats
we just wouldn't be able to use them for
food after because
the vampire bats would probably infect
that livestock
with rabies and we wouldn't only have to
worry about
feeding these big beasts we'd also have
to worry about
where they're going to live
usually bats live in groups of a few
hundred
to a few thousand in caves hollow trees
attics and barns clearly human sized
bats wouldn't
all fit into the same amount of space
anymore they
might need to create smaller groups and
take over buildings and parks
their sheer size food requirements and
bodily functions could damage their new
homes
but on the bright side their bodily
functions
could also make you rich bat
excrement also known as guano is an
effective fertilizer
it has high amounts of nitrogen
phosphate and potassium
and it can be very expensive
right now an average bat only releases
about two and a half grams of guano each
year
but with these new human sized bats
eating upwards of 19 kilograms every day
their guano production will increase
dramatically
so if you're brave enough to get near
these beastly creatures
to collect their poop you could make a
lot of money
all you'd have to do next is figure out
how to spend it
but that's a story for another
what if